I don't have anybody from my tribe of
atheists ever thank you for giving us a
shout out at your first inaugural but
you didn't mention non-believers that's
cute I think it was pardoned once more
than what I I mean it's not just in that
speech I've done it often well we
appreciate it because we do feel like
Untouchables to a degree I mean I don't
know if you saw the latest religion
survey but almost a quarter of the
country are nuns I don't mean the ones
who hit me on the knuckles with a ruler
in Sunday school I mean they put none
for religion of the above right right
they're not no they're atheists
agnostics or they just don't want to get
up on Sunday morning and we have no
representation in Congress if if our
numbers were represented to be over a
hundred Congress people who felt that
way it just seems like we are not
included in the basket of diversity in
America which is odd because we are the
biggest minority that is a bigger
minority than any other minority you can
name oh don't you think we should get a
little more love you know I guess my
question would be whether there is
active persecution of atheists I think
that there are certain well I I think
for a candidate I I think you're right
that there are certain we might be
occupations probably most prominently
politics where there would be a bias
against somebody who's agnostic or
atheist in running for office I think
that's still true outside of that arena
though you seem to have done all right
with your TV show I'm at I don't get it
sense but I'm really extent that they're
boycotting cue it's because of your
other wacky ideas rather than your
particular view on religion what a banth
or wacky idea the you know I usually
agree with you I I think I think the
average American if they go to the
workplace somebody's next to them
they're not poking around trying to
figure out what their religious beliefs
are so so so here's what I would say
that
I think that we should foster a culture
in which people's private religious
beliefs including atheists and agnostics
are respected and and and that's the
kind of culture that I think allows all
of us then to believe what we want
that's freedom of conscience that's what
our Constitution guarantees and you know
where we get into problems typically is
when our personal religious faith or the
community of faith that we participate
in tips into a sort of fundamentalist
extremism in which it's not enough for
us to believe what we believe but we
start feeling obligated to you know hit
you over the head because you don't
believe the same thing or to treat you
as as somebody who's less than than I am
but we might be more pro-science in
America if we were less religious don't
you think well you know I think the the
issues we have with science these days
are not restricted to to what's
happening with respect to religion I
there are a lot of very religious
scientists around I think the problem is
is that in our school systems and to
some degree and this is where it is
relevant with school boards around the
country that are mandating curriculums
and textbooks you start seeing this
weird watering down of scientific fact
so that our our kids are growing up in
an environment and this connects with a
to what I was saying earlier about the
media where everything's contested that
that nothing is true because if it's on
Facebook it all looks the same
and if you're reading something from a
Nobel prize-winning physicist next to
some guy
in his underwear it writin in his
basement yeah or his mom's basement in
on text it looks like it's equally
plausible and part of what we have to do
a better job of if our democracy is a
function in a complicated diverse
society like this is to teach our kids
enough critical thinking to be able to
sort out what is true and what is false
what is contestable and and what is
incontestable and and we seem to have
have trouble with that and and our our
political system doesn't help